le déconfinement se poursuit en europe
alors que les nouvelles hospitalisations
les chiffres des décès liés aux
coronavirus sont en chute libre sur le
continent la réouverture des frontières
avec les autres pays hors union
européenne pourrait avoir lieu dès le
mois prochain
la levée des restrictions temporaires de
voyage aux frontières extérieures
interviendra dans un deuxième temps est
à cet égard le collège des commissaires
européens adoptera dans le courant de la
semaine son évaluation des restrictions
de voyage
il proposera une approche pour la levée
progressive et partielle de ces
restrictions
à partir du 1er juillet avec certains
pays tiers en tenant compte d'un certain
nombre de principes et de critères sur
la base d'une approche commune
coordonnée des états membres est
soutenue par la commission l'exécutif
européen ne peut émettre qu'un avis la
décision finale appartient à chaque état
membre
l'allemagne a décidé de jouer la carte
de la prudence en prolongeant jusqu'au
31 août ses mises en garde sur les
voyages en dehors de l'union européenne
la liberté de circulation sera à nouveau
établi au sein de l'europe et l'union
européenne pour être précis une décision
prise en fonction de la situation due à
la pandémie
et si contrairement aux attentes cette
situation devait se détériorer
nous avons convenu que nous pourrons
reconsidérer des choses à tout moment de
son côté l'autriche a établi une liste
de 31 pays avec lesquels la liberté de
voyage va être établi le 16 juin la
suède l'espagne le portugal et le
royaume-uni en sont exclus
l'assouplissement des restrictions et
donc à l'ordre du jour partout dans le
monde
plusieurs dirigeants européens dont le
président français emmanuel macron et la
chancelière allemande angela merkel ont
néanmoins demandé cette semaine a lieu
que soit étudié les moyens de mieux se
préparer à la prochaine pandémie
estimant qu'elle n'avait pas été à la
hauteur à propos du coc vite 19